i'm in love with the building products
that just work i'm coming from the user
experience for marketing
and every aspect that is related to
growth
in the company it's building like a
massive project we are
building the data team in the in the
company and we have internal the tool in
the company that we call it jarvis this
is our
secret weapon
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about security with segeek co-founder
and cpo of perimeter 81.
zagie has been a serial entrepreneur
since he was 9 years old but instead of
printing and selling stickers he creates
scales and optimizes sas solutions
before he established perimeter 81 and
safer vpn with amit he worked as the ux
consultant for siemens
today segee leads all of perimeter 81's
demand generation marketing and design
during his army service he worked in the
idf's elite visual intelligence unit and
later was a software developer at
imperva he has a patent for the security
of public wi-fi networks and received
the bsc in computer science and
economics from tolbev university
the gigi dali welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
very good nice to meet you thank you
very much
[Music]
nice to meet you too thank you very very
much for being here and quite a quite an
interesting background you know
entrepreneurial from a very very young
age you know really
loving products and embracing them today
co-founder and cpo of perimeter 81 but
previously sold safer vpn to j2 global
so you know i'm really curious to hear
about your own perspective on the
entrepreneurial journey from such a
young age and sort of what is that bug
that keeps bothering you that leads you
to creating these awesome companies uh
both in the cyber world but also in the
stickers world and i'd love to start
over there tell me about you know how
you started as a kid
your very first business
yeah that's a
it's a good question that's my first
initiative
um i'm in love with with design that's
my passion in life to be creative to to
create things
so when i was a
eight years old i started like to to
fight with my brother
and i don't know why but my parents and
they bought us
a design program
and before photoshop and all of that
so they gave us the the program and um
apparently
it worked brilliantly we started to to
talk to teach ourselves
how to design and how to
to create a different things
so once we
we got to a professional level
uh we said that we can monetize it and
so i was in school
and what we did we started to design
stickers
for notebooks
and we sold it to two kids in
my class and other people in the school
itself
um
so it was like a very fun initiative
and ever since i did like many design
gigs in my career and
and also in the company today
and we have a big studio of eight
designers so i'm a big part of it wow
so you really started your journey as a
designer not as a
not even just product but you know a
designer and sort of founder of these
initiatives right
yeah so i started as a designer but both
me and me my co-founder we are computer
geeks
and so i started to deal with computer
when i was six years old i was also a i
did the programming
and i met him at the university we
studied computer science and economics
at tel aviv university and this is where
we started like our entrepreneurial
journey together
wonderful
what did that do to you that that
experience how how old were you when you
were selling those stickers
stickers i was nine years old
nine wow okay nine years ago that's even
younger than i thought
what does that do to a nine-year-old
starting a business designing selling
stickers creating value yeah what does
that do
it was fun i mean to see that people
like to
like what you do
and
so it was a very good good feeling and
they're motivating
so that was kind of like a one of the
drivers
and it brought me here today
and i'm always looking for new ways to
to create and do things so at that time
um i added the design program and my
father also bought us a printer
and
so we knew like how to combine and to do
this stuff together
and
so that's very very cool very very
nostalgic moment now
and
then transition from designing stickers
to a virtual virtual private networks
how does that work
yeah it's a good question and
so i think that like it's like they're
like you know like milestones in your
life
one of the milestones was in the army
this is like where everything is shaped
like my
my desire and to be an entrepreneur and
to do and to build companies
and
a i got into the virtual private uh
network world in by accident
um
me and domit we did a
we did a course together at the
university we did a project we bought an
application we built an application
and this application was to catch stolen
cars
um
so
we participated in a microsoft
it was a very interesting application by
the way i think that today there is a
company that is doing a similar thing
what we did we put the phone on the
windshield windshield day mount
and the camera was facing to the road
and every car that
went in front of the camera and the
phone took a picture automatically
and by using an algorithm
we
we managed to extract the license plate
number
and we compared it with
the police database
so this is what we did back in the
university and we got to a very nice mvp
that was working so we got in real time
answers about cars in the road if it's
stolen or not um
and
we wanted to raise money for this
initiative uh but it was very hard we
understood that it was dealing with
insurance companies and dealing with the
police and another a lot of broccoli
so
we decided to
to brainstorm so we did it like for two
months
looking for other ideas
and we were sitting in the google campus
and we participated in a program that
called the launch pad
so it was a two weeks of mentoring
pitching
and we met like many different people
and in one of the times there was a
ceo of an attack company that they came
to the campus and he told told us
amit sagi
i need a vpn solution for my business
today i'm paying tons of money what can
you do
and we said
i mean we didn't i didn't know like
about this market uh
anything and we said to him okay let us
say look
30 days from now you will have something
that that works
so eventually came back after 30 days
and we gave him like the first version
of safervpn
and it was our first uh paying a
customer
and so that's how we started
bootstrapped uh save for vpn so that's
like the beginning
of the story
and after that we did like a shift to
consumers we built a website we built
the entire like the payment system and
all of that
go to ten thousands of paying customers
and
learned a lot of things during the way
made tons of mistakes
one of them we lost 1 million dollars
um
i have to hear about that
so yeah so that was like another uh
that almost shut down the business
uh back then yeah and i can see that
you're laughing i don't think you were
laughing back then
no you know everything is good now but
uh but back then it was like very
stressful so what we did
we we wanted to change the website we
wanted to get a more organic visitors
so we did a huge project it took us like
more than six months to
a
redesign and rewrite add more content to
the website
and we also moved to a different system
but the thing is that we didn't do qa
so
when we pulled the plug on the old
website and they initiate launched the
new one
nothing worked
so
much and it took us a lot of time to
recover from the damage and so customers
couldn't
[Music]
pay for the service we couldn't acquire
new customers because there was a thing
with the billing system
and so this is like a a big thing that
we learned a huge lesson
um
and we implemented the the conclusions
uh here in player 81
and we learned a lot from it
wow
so you you sell save for vpn a quite an
experience overnight when
with the with the website and then you
decide to start another company
perimeter a181 a company you know one of
greatest israel's prides today that
probably every engineer here
knows very very well um
why why start another company after
selling save for vpn
so
it was a gradual process and a very like
a hard decision for us uh to do so to to
pivot from the uh first company so the
first company was a it was successful it
was a a profitable
uh but the product itself it was a
commodity
uh we wanted to go to like a bigger
larger a market
and in 2017
we heard like two trends in the market
first one we heard it from our customers
the first one was that
we saw the digital nomads people that
were walking from everywhere
me the beach coffee shops and homes way
before covered
and the second thing was about the shift
to the cloud cloud infrastructures
so there is no one perimeter the office
is not there the main perimeter anymore
as the resources are moving away to
different places so the user
is the center so the approach is also
changing to a user-centric approach
and that's where we understood that the
legacy solutions are not adequate to the
modern workforce
so
me and me who said okay that's a huge
market there's no
good solution for that
let's sell say for vpn and start from
scratch and build player 81
and that's basically what we did
yeah so we launched
2018.
yes i i want to know first what does the
81 represent because essentially you
know the perimeter you're talking about
you know the boundaries that we have
today are no longer the office
boundaries the geographical boundaries
of where we work together so so what
what is this 81 piece of it and then i
really want to to to give me you know
dumb it down for me what what is a vpn
and why are we why are virtual private
networks and an important part of our
new daily life in this digital ecosystem
okay so the 81 it's uh it's simple and
when we start to brand and strategize
the new uh
solution
the 81 we thought about like something
that would be like a gimmick or
something cool like a icebreaker with
the investors in the market
so at eight one is the unit
uh the intelligence unit in the
uh
in the defense forces amit is coming
from the eight one i'm coming from a
nine nine hundred so it's much longer
and doesn't go well so we stick with the
with the 81
um
so so that's a about that
and
regarding a vpn so
we gained lots of maturity
with the safer vpn how to
run networks in large scales automations
the sas experience how to create a
product that just
works in a very seamless
um
and and and we decided to
to transform to do that also like in the
in the business world a vpn is um it's
it's unnecessary it's a necessity
basically every company needs a way
to get a secure remote access
to
internal resources of the organization
if it's in the cloud
on the on-prem
um so you need a solution for that
and
the vpns and the legacy ones uh are not
good enough
they are like a ip based
vpns
um
they're protecting the the on-prem but
they're not a good solution for the
cloud resources and you need one
solution a one-stop shop
which is hybrid one which is a model one
that was born in the cloud
to handle this so that's why we
uh built um priority one
the first use case is ztna zero trust
network access which is a vpn
replacement
but
the vision
it's to build a holistic solution
uh gartner calls it a sassy secure
access service edge and it's a
consolidated solution
of network and network security uh
because we see that there is a paradox
the titan managers are using many
different tools we call it the
complexity trap
and by using many different tools it
creates vulnerabilities
so what we are doing is basically
one platform that contains many
different solutions
and by creating that simplicity
the meaning is security
so simplicity is a theme that comes up
often not only i guess on you know on on
the website and in your product but also
in the in the way that you're thinking
through the products
um
why why is it such a crucial piece of it
why is simplicity such an important
part that's
the
most common feedback that we get from
our more than 2000 customers of predator
is the ease of use
the user experience and that's why we
branded
a printer 81 as a cyber security
experience
platform
um
the idea is that
when you create something which is a
simple to to consume and simple to
er to use
you you reduce
the friction
for the user you can generate more
visibility
and you can generate more security and
more trust and credibility
and
by doing that and being like a my
experience my
ux experience my product experience
um that was one of our focuses
while building the product itself and
it's one of the key differentiators of
calendar 81 from our competitors that's
what allows us to gain more than one 31
40 new customers every month
incredible how do you test for that so
is there you know a way that you
know if if you now to look at somebody
and then sort of help them through
identifying the simplicity test of their
own product yeah you sort of like you
know the grandma test or the mom test
for an idea
what are some ways in which somebody can
contest for simplicity and have and
build with simplicity as top of mind
yeah so the answer is basically product
growth and the frictionless
process
so
a customer can
arrive to our website you can sign up
you can attach the credit card and you
can build his own network you don't need
to wait to the sales team you don't need
to wait
for implementation sessions you don't
need to wait
several weeks or months and for that
the idea is that overnight you can
transform your entire organization and
that's what we saw during the cavity
times
uh when it all started
we saw like a huge spike uh that many
organizations come came and started to
adopt and this type of technology and
the platform
right that makes sense now if you look
today at uc because i'm seeing this
dissonance here because oftentimes
you know when you're talking about cyber
security
i'm not facing a person who is so deeply
you know
involved with it with the idea of
building simplicity and building
products that people love and seeing the
delight experience and talking about the
aha moments in product like growth right
so are you more of a cyber security guy
a networks guy a product guy an
entrepreneur who is segee
i'm
so i understand cyber i understand the
networking but that's not my
forte
i'm
i'm in love with the building products
that they just walk i'm coming from the
user experience for marketing
and every aspect that is related to
growth
in the company it's building like a
massive project we are
building the data team in the in the
company and we have internal the tool in
the company that we call it jarvis this
is our
secret weapon that basically allows us
to take every tactical and the strategic
decision and we have a full team that is
engaged and on board
with this tool that contains tons of
information of every customer and
everything that we do with the very
sophisticated
algorithms and models so
i love to find ways to
to crack
the product market fit
to engage the conversion to increase the
conversion to engage more with the with
the customers to find more new ideas
uh that can do that and that's what i do
in the company i'm pushing the teams uh
so i'm just planning the scene
and i'll tell people here
where do you get the inspiration from to
to continue pushing to continue
innovating to continue being creative
and and aim for simplicity
i read a lot i walk a lot my brain is
all the time is like thinking thinking
thinking what i can do i see like what
our other companies are doing i see what
our competitors are doing i see like the
um
i take ideas from other successful
companies that combine and do a mishmash
from that i'm coming like with new ideas
it just pops out
and and i know somehow it's working
well i have a feeling it's you know just
like a lot of things it's not an over it
never nothing is an overnight success
and it requires a lot of hard work and
energy and with the experience that
you're bringing here and your mentality
i think it's it really shows and and and
i now understand why people are are so
you know inspired by the by the work of
perimeter 81 and yeah and so so yeah i
really want to thank you for for coming
here yeah go ahead
yeah i just want to say that it's not a
one-man show it's all it's all about the
people that you have around you
and you must be surrounded with super
talented and super innovative and
creative
people that can push and take it forward
incredible so again thank you very very
much this was um
amazing and inspiring and and i love
your product and i love the journey and
the vision so thank you and stay safe
and stay healthy
[Music]